il agace le plus quand vous surnomme
bigoudis à cause de votre calvitie qu'on
imite vos imitations ou alors que
stéphane collaro me transforme en crabe
rien de plus la mairie de lagaf' bon
rien du tout non pour agissent et bien
moi je vous dis je le trouve plus ou
moins réussies séjour du public qui doit
réagir je suis venu mal placé voire à
une opinion mais sommes guéris pourquoi
coup les routes s'améliorer krasucki
chez chez colaert on vous trouvez
comment
d'après ce que j'ai compris il a voulu
présenter un
prolo un métallo parisien type qui m'a
même dit un mégot alors vu un film pas
important puis c'est tout pour le reste
de bastille c'est son affaire lui est
publique et bigoudis vous connaissiez ce
surnom aux journées beaucoup de surnoms
à vide entre les quais et
un deuxième surnom très vite comme ça
s'est vu vous avez vu la une du matin de
paris la semaine dernière vont parler du
look de la cgt alors quand on lisait
l'article on s'apercevait que c'était
juste une manchette de journalistes
qu'est ce que vous croyez pas que le
look krasucki c'est à dire le côté un
peu voyeur comme ça la casquette est ce
qu'on va il est vrai que cela peut
décourager certaines professions de des
cadres des professeurs de s'engager de
de militer à la cgt ce que vous croyez
pas que vous donnez à l'essai était
finalement un look un peu trop pro
l'hologramme
pense pas gagner spécialement lourds
locaux que je suis comme je suis et
ensuite la cgt quand sera même pas à une
personne n'y a ni à son allure on a la
tête qu'on a et donc il ya l'image qu'on
fabrique il ya la réalité des personnes
et de l'organisation vous me parliez de
du matin de paris c'était un titre
incorrect une soirée jambon des
paralysés la route des grands fauves
exprimer ça n'était pas innocent ouais
et c'est le nom n'est pas une affaire de
justice j'ai réagi en protestant
le matin de paris a approuvé une
protestation
je tiens à me faire respecter et à faire
respecter l'organisation que je
reprenant non pas pour en revenir à
votre question saxon la diversité des
salariés je veux voir à présent passer
du monde du travail tel qu'il est je
pense que c'est lui qui ont pêché une
catégorie sociale quand je me trouve
j'ai souvent l'occasion de rencontrer
des ingénieurs des cadres supérieurs qui
décrit sert bien sûr les scientifiques
je visite jeudi ce quiz nous comprenons
et ils n'ont pas l'impression de parler
à un extraterrestre qui vous arrête
c'est positif je vous donne trois
minutes et vous allez essayer de me
convaincre de rentrer à la cgt
vous avez trois minutes comme dit bout
vous êtes une salariée
il vous arrive où il peut vous arriver
d'avoir bourré défendre vos intérêts
dont salariés
salaire avancement sécurité de l'emploi
dignité aussi
vous avez besoin
d'être organisé tout seul on peut vous
arriver de le dézinguer l'importance et
syndicale est d'accord mais pourquoi le
secteur j'y viens mais d'abord d'abord
l'idée s'est regroupée alors pourquoi le
sait la cgt mais parce que
citez moi un seul bulletin plus combatif
que la cgt
plus proche des préoccupations des gens
tout lui ferme dans les discussions avec
n'est pas content il a la pudeur est la
pile sorte de défaut je n'ai en tout cas
essayer de la semaine sinon elle ne vous
convient pas et bien contribué à le
faire comme vous voudriez qu'ils soient
mais ne restez pas seul parce que comme
salarié vous êtes en faire et ce
passionnant
si vous commencez à faire engager mes
salariés la cgt sabine est très mal pour
moi là bas je veux seulement quand on me
faut ce qu'ils sont là je demande une
augmentation de
30 ans a succombé d'un rêve c'est
convaincant c'est cette fois ci alors
maintenant je voulais une question
d'image et écoutez moi je vis je veux
venir moi je ne cherche pas comme sien à
convaincre milan ac je veux donner déjà
fléchi revêt alors écoutez moi fait
partie des gens qui pensaient que le
bilan des pays de l'est est globalement
positif
vous avez participé en septembre 86 à
berlin-est et une réunion de la fsm de
temps peut réconcilier un conte vélo 11e
on peut réconcilier avec eux et vous
vous êtes maintenant et des
vice-présidents de la fsm en compagnie
de roumains de bulgares de cech de
russes et d'allemands de l'est aux yeux
de beaucoup d'hôtels et d'acides gras la
question est ce que vous mangez krasucki
aujourd'hui vous vivriez dans un pays de
l'est avaient d'abord je suis français
oui bon alors moi j'aime bien vivre
henry d'accord sur tout alors parce que
ce genre de questions vous voyez ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens ah non moi je vis
en france et je par contre j'ai une
certaine idée de comment on pourrait
vivre mieux en france et reed est devenu
en france c'est un peu se rapprocher des
pays arabes a même pas du tout on peut
pas au sens de copier ce qui se fait
dans tel terme aubry notant qu'il s'agit
il ya ya certaines choses qui
l'intéressent
certaines choses m'intéressent c'est
peut-être sur un caractère fort
cependant je trouve qu'il ya des
injustices et des inégalités sociales le
système est bien c'est énorme il n'ya
pas communiste le dise il ya aussi les
coteaux lui qui disent que tout le monde
devient alors un vrai partage et je
pense donc je considère que telle qu
elle s est inquiété a besoin d'être
changé et a fait mais à la française
disons attention de notre histoire de la
manière de vivre des français et c'est
tout à fait autre chose bien mais mais
vous ne me ferez pas sous prétexte que
celle des jeux un espace de faire
changer d'avis qui est tel ou tel défaut
renoncé à comprendre ce qui se passe
d'important dans ces pays date ce qui
s'y est passé là bas si je prends
l'union celui
ci est la fée ya 70 ans c'est
l'équivalent à notre siècle de ce que la
révolution française a fait il ya deux
siècles en scène mais il pose une
question définitive ça sera la dernière
et j'aimerais qu'on me répondiez le plus
franchement possible
vous avez eu le malheur pendant la
guerre d'être déportés
aujourd'hui en urss on n'est pas sans
savoir qu'il existe des camps de
concentration comment pouvez vous serrer
la main de ces gens là vous savez quand
l'urss les juifs n'ont pas le droit de
sortir du rss comment pouvez vous serrez
la main ce journal
pouvez-vous me poser des questions et un
journaliste aussi peu
raisonnable parce que non aujourd'hui ça
existait mais aujourd'hui en urss
ignoble axe n'existe pas aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui il y a parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu non plus en plus de crise ont ils
ont un système pénitentiaire qui est
basé sur des camps de travail ils disent
que c'est pour une rééducation mais ça
concerne des gens est prisonnier de
droit commun ils n'ont pas de
prisonniers politiques il y en a eu nous
avons que vous dites aujourd'hui rihanna
nous avons protesté
sinon est ce qu elles sont en train de
régler cette question et vous le savez
des réformes sur lui en union soviétique
en ce moment notamment sur la question
des droits de l'homme y compris sur la
liberté de circulation des juifs ou de
tout autre c'est que les juifs en effet
c'est mes jeux comme elle l'est refusent
d qui n'ont pas droit de sortir
justement je suis en train de vous dire
cette question qui nous a amenés à
critiquer à discuter alors dire mais
pour pourquoi vous laissez pas ces gens
circuler sorti un cd aujourd'hui c'est
en cours de règlement vous pensez que
j'entends du bruit mais pas seulement je
pense pas que c'est parce que seulement
nous avons donné notre avis nous avons
joué un rôle est utile
justement à l'époque où nous reprocher
de ne de ne pas crier nous avons dit ce
qu'il fallait publiquement quand c'était
nécessaire aujourd'hui ça va bien c'est
en train de changer sérieusement et
personne ne conteste dans le milieu de
l'information j'ai grand jour alors je
reprenais par votre question parce que
parce que c'est la fin des gens comme un
bon collègue ce moment sont en train de
devenir prudent oui la tombe pour eux
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux